my next guest is an award-winning
fashion designer and one of Time
Magazine's 100 most influential people
recently he's taken his talent to the
frontlines of the pandemic I'm happy to
call him a friend Christian Siriano yo
how you doing
let me tell ya but the world has changed
a bit since we last saw each other so
how are you staying sane and all of this
yeah I know it's been which has really
got hit pretty hard there's a good place
to see everything closed and it's kind
of wild and but I've been listening to
the you know something to the governor
kind of everyday and there was such like
a shortage of bangs and I was like well
maybe I can do something so that's kind
of like why I started just kind of
pitching in I felt like maybe we could
help and that was kind of it I just felt
like I couldn't sit at home and do
nothing it's so devastating like you're
in a very devastating area with with
this whole virus and and you know it's
really cool though I just wanted to say
thank you because you you could just be
chillin and doing nothing you know
saying you could just be relaxing and
like a lot of people are just like okay
I'm just gonna stay safe and healthy and
you heard a need for something and then
use your talent for this and it's super
cool and I just wanted to say thank you
for doing that for something you know
like everybody doing something matters
so what is the process though of making
masks that that's very different from
dresses and outfits job like yes is that
hard it's like I mean I literally after
like I tweeted at the governor and they
responded you know they gave us kind of
permission to open my office with a
small team and I realize you know my
sellers are like Couture so ores and now
they're like making that it's it's quite
a monotonous work it's the same thing
over and over going and at the beginning
we were only making like white and now
like we need to have some color like I
need something because we've done like
almost 15,000 masks and you're like oh
my god your eyes like are like bulging
out because it's the same thing and it
kind of it kind of hard to make quality
control when you you know I didn't
have a mask factory and I just kind of
turn it into line so it's kind of yeah
because there are like I guess
specifications in what the mask has to
be able to do in the filtration yeah
it's great we've looked at it too
because I quilt and I've I thought of
doing it with my five-year-old like on
our little assign machine here just
starting to make stuff and I was like oh
gosh I gotta figure out all how to do
that I was like it's so crazy and it's
really hard oh my god but it's really
cool that I like doing that but um so
and I'll actually love that you did the
color and you added the color because I
know that seems like a silly thing but
we could use color right now we're in
such a black-and-white scenario like
color can make people happy like when I
see the color yellow it helps me when I
see the color you know rich vibrant
colors it just helped me so I think
that's actually smart I know it seems
silly but not know but like even though
even the women in my office or like
working every day to like still like
have a job and like even families they
different when they're like making a
fuchsia mask all day instead of just a
plain grey well like you can tell in
their in their face you know which is
really absolutely yeah I mean is this
this is kind of cool to just as a
business owner like I mean you run a
business and your family's like you know
and they need to be fed and so that's
it's kind of a difficult position for a
lot of owners of businesses because
their income early isn't coming in so
it's like is this kind of a way you
thought that would be cool to kind of
keep them going and then also help out
the community yeah it's like the best of
both worlds we get to I mean we get to
spend thousands of things to hospitals
kind of roam around the u.s. which is
amazing and then also like my you know
my seamstresses my pattern makers
everybody that works my office you know
who has you know five kids some of them
they get to see their job and that was
what I was actually so scared about it
was like what can we do we make clothes
we don't sit at home and work on the
internet we we make something every day
so we have to go and do it
it's clever and it's helpful um so how
can people help you like with the work
you're doing can anybody help or yeah
yeah we've just been having everybody go
to Christian Siriano comm we have like
everything there like information how
you can help or even if people want to
like help their friends by making mass
so all that's on my website yeah that's
awesome
what's your personal version of Pia
till noon quarantine batcher oh my gosh
it's really funny because I have noticed
like I'm really into like everybody in
their looks and like I'd love the pillow
challenge I think she I get dressed
every day like I wear jeans and you know
and I like me too because otherwise and
I won't do anything I really will be
lazy and I can't I have to keep active
oh my gosh I am able to conquer the
world in pajama pants well have you seen
any corn seeing fashion on social media
do you love you mentioned the pillow say
what's the pillow thing the pillows
challenges where you take your pillow
and you basically belt it you like to
make a gown out of it you have is so
fabulous it's amazing so one thing I did
want to ask because I saw this when you
first came on and I saw the video
there's like so many drawings behind you
so are you like are you just drawing are
you creating like crazy because a lot of
I've been writing like crazy so have you
just been drawing like non-stop it's
like my self-care is like painting and
sketching and like that's like my little
escapism I actually it just you know
while I'm here well I did happy birthday
present for you and I sketched you our
three favorite looks this is Grandma
Golden Globes and trolls premier and
these are my gifts you I'm sorry they're
not frame because my frame are clearly
isn't working
birthday subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going